we're gonna turn overseas now and that
crucial NATO Summit and some harsh words
from Ukraine's president because
President Biden and other NATO leaders
have so far declined to put a timeline
on when Ukraine can join the military
Alliance Lloyd mirzolinski says that
fact could embolden Russia Nancy Cordes
is at The Summit in Vilnius Lithuania
for us Nancy good morning
Good morning Tony and zelenski is
sharing those concerns directly with
President Biden here today they are
meeting one on one a short time ago
zielinski told reporters he understands
that his country can't join NATO right
now that that could spark a World War
but he said his battered Nation needs
some post-war guarantees
we want to be
on the same page with everybody
Ukraine's president arrived at NATO
morning seeking seeking Clarity he did
not get yesterday when the NATO leaders
gathered here
mamas to let Ukraine join their Alliance
at some point in the future the
invitation will be issued when
conditions are met zielinski called the
ambiguity absurd I want to discuss with
our partners all these things The Clash
has exposed a division among NATO's 31
member nations
with Ukraine under constant attack from
Russia some allies want to give Ukraine
full NATO protections as soon as
possible others including the U.S say
Ukraine must make reforms first all
countries have to demonstrate a certain
basic standards of the rule of law Colin
call is U.S under Secretary of Defense
Ukraine wants a timeline Ukraine's
President says he needs a timeline he
needs specifics why can't he have those
well look if I was him I'd wanted to uh
they are I think very keen to have a
security guarantee by NATO but the fact
of the matter is no country tree in the
history of the alliances had a timeline
so
[Applause]
start for zielinski here in
undeniable
promising more range missiles tanks and
armored vehicles and for the first time
training for Ukrainian pilots on
American f-16s
and there's more today the leaders of
the world's seven largest economies are
announcing that their countries are
making major new investments in
Ukraine's military to help build it up
for the long term a move they say is
going to send a powerful message at
least they hope so to Vladimir Putin
that time is not on his side tarika
Nancy Cordes at the NATO Summit thank
you